bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction de tvfiles il est 18h si vous
nous suivez en direct et voici les
titres de l'actualité locale de ce 3
février 2015 la principale fédération de
l'éducation la FFU appelée à la grève
nationale conditions de travail
formation revalorisation des salaires et
les principaux mots d'ordre nous verrons
si le mouvement a été suivi dans les
Yvelines le 73e Paris Nice a livré son
parcours certains le jugent plus
classique ils partira en tout cas du
département et nous en parlerons avec
François Lemarchand le directeur de la
course qui s'élancera le 8 mars c'était
une première la Semaine du son en
Île-de-France sortait de la capitale
pour sa journée de clôture ce week-end
c'était à Trappes un rendez-vous qui
sensibilise à l'importance des sons et à
la qualité de notre environnement sonore
quelques chiffres pour débuter cela
concerne les départementales les
élections selon le dernier sondage
bvaporité les 26% des Français
voteraient pour un binôme du Front
national dans leur canton si les
élections avaient lieu en ce moment 25%
pour l'UMP et 18% pour le PS le Front
national dans le département des
Yvelines annoncera des candidats partout
ce sera pour une présentation officielle
des listes cette semaine le 5 février
enregistrement auprès de la préfecture
pour tous les candidats qui débuteront
le 9 février nous aurons bien sûr
l'occasion d'en reparler dans ce genre
là la mobilisation dans l'éducation
assez peu suivi malgré tout plusieurs
écoles ont été fermées aujourd'hui en
raison de ce mouvement de grève lancée
principalement par le syndicat FSU les
raisons de la colère d'une partie de la
profession avec Mélanie poker
des cours de récréation desert pas un
bruit autour des établissements une
scène commune dans des écoles 50 chinois
ce mardi les professeurs grévistes ont
plusieurs revendications
c'est la mise en place des nouveaux
rythmes scolaires
qui s'est faite d'une façon assez
anarchique qui a désorganisé
complètement les écoles à titre purement
indicatif il y a une circonscription des
Yvelines où il y a 38 horaires
différents donc il est évident qu'après
ça impacte forcément
les situations de remplacement de
complément de service etc je vais donner
un autre exemple qui est celui des
remplacements nous sommes ici à Trappes
depuis la rentrée de janvier c'est entre
14 à 20 professeurs qui ne sont pas
remplacés chaque jour sur les écoles de
Trappes donc effectivement ce sont des
désorganisations
c'est une continuité de l'enseignement
qui ne peut pas être assurée c'est des
gros problèmes puisque une partie des
enfants sont répartis d'autres sont
envoyés donc une surcharge de d'élèves
dans les classes
il faut savoir que un jeune professeur
des écoles commence à 117% du SMIC que
cette année alors je vais passer sur les
sur les
péripéties mais il faut savoir que les
jeunes professeurs des écoles qui
commencent cette année sont moins bien
payés que ceux qui ont commencé à
l'année dernière et quand à la grille
générale des enseignants elle est très
en deçà de la moyenne de l'OCDE
d'ailleurs ça se traduit dans les
difficultés qu'il y a recrutées l'année
dernière pour la première fois le
concours professeur des écoles n'a pas
fait le plein
les jeunes professeurs des écoles
stagiaires servent de moyens
d'enseignement ils doivent assurer un
demi-service ce ne sont pas des bonnes
conditions de de comment dirais-je de
formation initiale l'année dernière ils
assuraient une journée par semaine
maintenant ces deux jours une semaine
deux jours et demi l'autre semaine
sachant que dans le même temps ils
doivent valider un Master 2 donc ils
sont submergés de travail
l'université a beaucoup de mal à
organiser des horaires réguliers pour
eux ce sont ce n'est absolument pas des
conditions satisfaisantes de formation
initiale
le sa nuit PP FSU Yvelines annonce 15 à
20% d'enseignants grévistes pour le
rectorat ils étaient près de 12% dans le
premier degré et les collèges
toujours dans le domaine de l'éducation
samedi la ville de La Verrière
appelle-la une nouvelle mobilisation
devant la mairie devant le collège
également Philippe de Champaigne de
cortège qui vont se retrouver ensuite au
rond-point de la gare aux alentours de
11h les élus entendent une fois de plus
protester contre le nouveau découpage du
réseau d'éducation prioritaire si l'État
ne revient pas sur son projet les
effectifs vont augmenter et les moyens
chuter prévient le maire Alain jage
mobilisation donc ce samedi à La
Verrière la course soleil premier étant
fort de la saison de cyclisme vient de
dévoiler son parcours ce matin nous en
parlons dans un instant sur ce plateau
avec elles sont directeur dans mais pour
l'instant un aperçu de ce qui attend les
coureurs avec ce reportage de Michael el
midoro
le tracé du Paris-Nice 2015 a été
dévoilé par Amaury Sport Organisation
cela devient une habitude pour la
sixième année consécutive les premiers
coups de de cette 73e édition
seront donnés depuis le département des
Yvelines Maurepas a été sélectionné pour
accueillir le prologue le 8 mars
prochain le peloton s'élancera également
de Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse pour la
première étape programmée le lendemain
on est toujours très heureux non
seulement de partir des Yvelines pour la
compétition sportive mais aussi parce
qu'il y a autour de la compétition un
tas d'événements et je pense au village
qui était installé aux randonnées qui
sont faites c'est un département
cyclable quand on dit vous savez l'eau
dans les Yvelines ça veut vraiment dire
quelque chose on voit de plus en plus de
cyclo le week-end ou en semaine profiter
des côtes profiter du terrain c'est vrai
qu'on est tout près de Paris quand même
temps on est aussi à la campagne donc
pour les gens à bicyclette comme pour
les champions à vélo c'est un
département quasiment idéal pour la
pratique du cyclisme le prologue de
Maurepas long de 6 km 700 est très
technique des écarts entre les
concurrents sont à prévoir dès ce
contre-la-montre le départ ne sera pas
au même endroit que l'arrivée donc ça
sera vraiment deux endroits distincts
distincts avec un kilomètre de
différence entre entre ces deux points
là mais c'est un parcours en campagne
carrément en campagne la première partie
c'est une partie boisée et ensuite un
retour vers mon repas vers une
difficulté on va dire que c'est la
croûte du donjon je vais l'appeler comme
ça parce qu'on passe pas loin du donjon
et avec des relances pour aller chercher
l'arrivée donc boulevard Michel Miserey
donc c'est pas un parcours tout plat
c'est pas des grandes routes c'est
vraiment assez technique et on pourrait
avoir des surprises après ces étapes
très prisé par les cyclistes amateurs
les routes sinueuses de
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse ont été remises
au programme de ce Paris-Nice 2015 c'est
vrai qu'on a fait une arrivée d'étape en
2012 à Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse du
contre-la-montre là on va y repartir
mais Saint-Rémy c'est dans la valise on
est bien abrité du vent et après 3 km il
y a une difficulté c'est la seule
difficulté elle est pas très dure mais
cette seule difficulté qui compte pour
le classement du meilleur grimpeur donc
ce qui veut dire qu'à l'arrivée bien il
y aura un maillot de de distribué donc
je pense que ça va partir très vite le
décor est désormais planté les stars du
cyclisme Jean-Christophe Perrot Thomas
voclor Bradley Wiggins sont encore Richy
porte doivent maintenant écrire le
scénario de cette course du soleil
premier chapitre le 8 mars prochain à
Maurepas
la Course au Soleil départ donc le 8
mars pour quelques-uns des meilleurs
coureurs du monde cela débutera à
Maurepas dans les Yvelines bonsoir
François Lemarchand bonsoir et bienvenue
on vient de vous voir dans ce reportage
pour évoquer le coup d'envoi de cette
compétition c'était lors de la
conférence de presse lorsque le parcours
a été dévoilé ce matin et tout d'abord
un mot sur le lien avec le département
des Yvelines le lien entre le parrainis
et le département yvelinois c'est la
sixième année consécutive c'est la
sixième année
consécutive on a commencé en 2010 à
Montfort-l'Amaury et l'aventure et bien
continuer et pour finir cette année
enfin pour continuer cette année à
Maurepas et on est allé un peu partout
on a fait des des étapes en ligne à
Mantes-la-Jolie à Houdan on a fait des
prologues à Houilles à Montfort-l'Amaury
également donc divers parcours et ça
nous plaît bien et pourquoi justement
les Yvelines parce que il y a une
variété de parcours il y a beaucoup
d'options possibles pour commencer la
course
historiquement ça part de Paris je la
vends pas mais il faut absolument
puisse rattacher cette épreuve à la
région parisienne il y a de moins en
moins d'épreuves sur sur Paris sur la
région parisienne même chez les amateurs
on a encore Paris Mantes en Yvelines qui
existent mais c'est vrai qu'il y en a
beaucoup moins il y a un peu moins de
clubs malgré tous les lycées il y a
moins de clubs donc il faut absolument
qu'on garde cette attache en
Île-de-France et dans les Yvelines et de
permettre à tous ces tous ces gens qui
font du vélo le dimanche matin qu'on
rencontre on va les Chevreuse de pouvoir
aller voir les les champions parce que
c'est la seule course professionnelle
qui existe en Île-de-France aujourd'hui
non seulement des Yvelines aiment le
vélo aiment le cyclisme le département
des Yvelines même le vélo elle me
cycliste je suis un ancien coureur
cycliste professionnel j'habite pas loin
d'ici et mes routes d'entraînement
c'était dans les Yvelines donc il y
avait un superbe terrain de jeu du côté
de la forêt de Rambouillet du côté de la
vallée de Chevreuse on parlait tout à
l'heure on a vu tout à l'heure des
images de la côte des 17 tournants donc
c'est ça parle pour pour les cyclistes
ça parle beaucoup donc et bien on va
rendre à ces gens là et bien un beau
spectacle on veut donner un beau
spectacle avec tous ces coureurs
professionnels qui seront là à Maurepas
le 8 mars donc ça débutera par ce
prologue vous l'avez dit déjà sur le
parcours en général on va revenir sur le
prologue mais sur le parcours en général
ça change de la saison dernière on dit
que les rollers sont avantagés cette
année et en effet on essaye de faire des
parcours différents parce que on aime
pas trop les courses stéréotypées les
équipes s'adaptent au parcours s'adapte
aux règlements donc on essaie de
modifier les parcours non passer nous
avions un Paris sans contre-la-montre
sans arriver au sommet on a on a
souhaité que la course soit ouverte
cette année on revient à la tradition
avec un chrono avec un prologue un
prologue assez je veux pas dire assez
dur mais où il y aura des écarts on
espère avec avec cela que des coureurs
comme Bradley viggins ou le champion du
monde du contre-la-montre et Tony Martin
pourront s'exprimer on a trouvé
également une arrivée au sommet à Croix
de Chaubouret du côté de Saint-Étienne
pour les grimpeurs et pour finir et bien
une une un autre contre la montre le
coldez et quelques étapes de sprinter
donc il y en aura pour tout le monde
donc cette année c'est vraiment vraiment
pour aller de Paris à Nice la France et
ça est ainsi faite on a on a la bosse on
a des étapes de plaine on a la
géographie le relief et fait ainsi et on
essaye de qu'il n'y ait pas de de trop
de d'arriver au sprint cette année il y
en aura trois l'année dernière il y en
avait beaucoup moins mais on essaie de
trouver d'autres d'autres difficultés
pour permettre justement à ce coureurs
et bien de pouvoir venir si on fait trop
d'arriver au sprint les la course est
bloqué par les par les par les sprinters
et si on fait trop dur et ça va être
bloqué par par les grimpeurs et si on
fait trop de Chronos ça va être bloqué
par les par les coureurs spécialistes du
contre-la-montre donc on essaye de
panacher on essaie de trouver des
solutions ça fait beaucoup de
contraintes et en tout cas pour le coup
d'envoi ce sera dans le département des
Yvelines pour le 8 mars pour la
compétition mais c'est dès le 7 sera des
animations pour les amateurs de vélo ce
sera donc un Maurepas village tous
cycliste en Yvelines qui sera qui sera
installé comment ça va se faire un petit
peu cette fête du vélo ce fait du
cyclisme sur sur Maurepas vous avez
participé oui mais d'assez d'assez loin
donc moi je me suis occupé du parcours
dans mon repas mais je sais que nous
pour la veille pour la permanence de
Paris Nice et bien ça va ça va commencer
à 14h à Maurepas on va recevoir les
équipes on va y aller des réunions
directeur sportifs on va recevoir des
coureurs aussi parce qu'on est des
messages à faire passer au coureur et
parallèlement à ça et bien il y aura une
journée cycliste pour les pour pour les
Yves Linois et même ailleurs il y aura
des randonnées donc ça sera vraiment la
fête du vélo on a vu ça l'année dernière
à Mantes les autres années également
c'est tous les ans c'est pareil ils ont
passé à Nantes parce qu'il faisait très
beau on espère qu'il fera très beau
cette année et c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit
que qu'il y a des choses à faire en
Île-de-France le vélo n'est pas n'est
pas mort les gens aiment le vélo alors
justement on va faire une petite pause
dans cet entretien chaque soir vous avez
la parole avec notre micro-trottoir
question du jour traditionnel
aujourd'hui nous sommes allés vous
demander ce que vous pensiez du cyclisme
du monde du vélo en général vos réponses
le vélo comme le footing en fait c'est
des sports qu'on peut pratiquer
régulièrement à moindre frais et partout
quoi en fait je pense tout de suite au
Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et voilà et sinon je pense au cyclisme
les pistes cyclables en ville qui sont
pas mal développés à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines j'aime bien le
vélo en plus c'est un moyen de faire du
sport sans s'en rendre compte très
économique et c'est un bon plan pour
l'environnement le vélo c'est bien c'est
un bon sport
de France la semaine du 15
voir les demi-finales j'ai bien regardé
le vélo j'ai fait toujours un peu de VTT
de temps en temps
est apprécié le cyclisme est apprécié on
est loin de l'image qui a eu un moment
aussi du dopage qui a beaucoup entaché
forcément le cyclisme on est obligé à
chaque fois d'y revenir mais vous avez
veillé aussi ne serait-ce que sur la
compétition Parisis à ne pas avoir des
cadeaux pages comment s'effectue les
contrôles pour redorer un petit peu le
blason de la discipline mais vous avez
depuis quelques années
le milieu c'est quand même assez assez
ni et
mais il faut pas relâcher il faut rien
relâcher et là au départ de Paris c'est
bien il y aura bien évidemment des
contrôles tous les coureurs seront
seront contrôlés ça c'est on est obligé
de passer par là
il y a eu des cas mais là aujourd'hui le
monde du vélo va beaucoup beaucoup mieux
d'ailleurs vous regardez les parfois les
moyennes sont elles sont moins élevées
et puis il y a des défaillances le
milieu du fin le sport cycliste c'est
des c'est des exploits mais c'est aussi
des défaillances donc on retrouve toute
tout cela et et
on l'entend avec ces commentaires des
gens c'est que c'est un beau sport avant
on disait oui mais faut être dopé pour
pouvoir en faire mais non tout le monde
peut tout le monde peut en faire il
suffit de s'entraîner il suffit d'avoir
des jeunes de vie très très fort et on y
arrive est-ce que les meilleurs coureurs
seront présents pour ce parrainisme bien
on espère on a pas mal de tête
d'affiches maintenant la course c'est
dans un peu plus d'un mois donc d'ici là
il y aura peut-être des changements
j'espère qu'il y aura des changements
dans le bon sens
italienne alors on va dire que la course
italienne c'est pour les c'est pour les
sprinters c'est pour les spécialistes de
Milan-San Remo même si le vainqueur de
1900 Remo l'an passé est venu sur Paris
Nice donc il y a pas forcément de
logique avec ça mais deux grandes
compétitions donc forcément il y a une
concurrence entre les deux pour attirer
les meilleurs moments il y a une
concurrence mais je dirais que Paris -
Nice c'est plus une course pour
pour préparer le Tour de France même si
le Tour de France c'est c'est dans
quelques mois mais on retrouve quand
même les gabarits de du Tour de France
ce qui fait plaisir cette année c'est
que on aura on aura des sprinter il y
avait des sprinters comme grippel par
exemple André grippel qui a gagné une
étape du Tour l'an passé et bien qui ne
venait pas sur Paris 10 ou très peu et
qui va venir cette année se frotter à
nos coureurs Bouani démarre et même
l'allemand de gaine COB on a Tony Martin
qui est qui est revenu on a le Vikings
qui qui fera certainement sa dernière
course
sur ce sur ce pari-nice donc on a un
beau plateau on a aussi un bon coureur
qui a gagné deux étapes la dernière sur
Tour de France rafale Mashka donc les
Français vont briller les for conclure
et bien les Français on a quand même
romain Bardet je pense qu'il y a un
moment un moment il va conclure il va y
arriver quand même bon on arrive à
croître chaud bourré on va pas dire
qu'on a fait le parcours pour les
Français mais là voilà ils ont les
cartes à eux de jouer il a aussi
Jean-Christophe Perrot et Tony Gallopin
donc il y a de quoi dynamiter la course
et que les Français que le public
mortasien est vivant en tout cas soit
présent au départ pour les encourager
merci François Le Marchand d'être assis
sur le plateau nous parler de cette
course Paris-Nice dont le parcours vient
d'être dévoilé ce matin début le 8 mars
et même le sûrement pas pour les
animations et font de la compétition le
15 mars dans le sud merci à vous nous
reprenons le cours de cette édition avec
un logo à vous montrer à présent c'est
la nouvelle signalétique des bases de
loisirs de la région Île-de-France qui
deviennent par la même occasion des îles
de loisirs elles sont 12 l'objectif
moderniser leur image et laisser plus de
place au rêve c'est comme ça que c'est
présenté pour les visiteurs en tout cas
clôture ce week-end en culture à présent
de la douzième semaine du son une
clôture d'une semaine nationale qui
s'est déroulée à Trappes à l'école de
musique en présence du président du
festival l'ingénieur acousticien
Christian Hugonnet le parrain de ce
festival cette année le réalisateur
Costa-Gavras Catherine zulato et David
charpentier pour les images
attention
prendre conscience de l'importance du
son mesuré son volume à cet essentiel
quand on sait que 15 à 20% des jeunes
ont des problèmes auditifs déterminer le
timbre d'un instrument noté l'acoustique
d'une salle et aller au-delà de la
vision purement culturelle du son voilà
tous les objectifs de cette semaine 12e
du nom à sa création un ingénieur
acousticien ingénieur du son Christian
Hugonnet
il y a une dimension sociétale qui
extrêmement forte parce qu'on considère
que le sonore quand il est maîtrisé et
bien il permet à tout un chacun de mieux
vivre
de savoir écouter l'autre et le dernier
point c'est une dimension économique
dont on parle pas assez encore si la
dimension qui nous laisse à penser que
lorsqu'on s'intéresse au sonore on peut
un pays peut
en tout cas éviter de perdre de l'argent
aujourd'hui équiper des gens et des
prothèses auditives ça coûte de l'argent
un pays qui n'entendrait pas ça serait
un pays qui serait vous à l'échec sera
plus en économique pour Costa-Gavras
réalisateur et parrain de cette douzième
semaine le son c'est un lien
indispensable avec le scénario d'un film
retenu à Londres c'est par téléphone qui
l'exprime sa pensée
le spectateur a mis le comprendre
l'histoire à mieux comprendre les
sentiments des
personnages du film et il aide aussi le
personnage à mieux s'exprimer le son est
donc multiples Christian agonet milite
pour que la pratique musicale des plus
jeunes deviennent obligatoire comme en
Grande-Bretagne aux États-Unis une
pratique que Gabriela Boda Staner mène
au sein de la maîtrise des enfants de
Trappes grâce à la méthode coda ils
apprennent le solfège de façon plus
ludique
la maîtrise des enfants qui a offert un
concert avec l'orchestre professionnel
manifesto en résidence depuis 4 ans dans
la commune un concert de clôture ici
tout un symbole dans ces temps quand
même de violence moi je vois là à
Trappes que il y a des enfants qui sont
juifs des enfants qui sont marocains moi
je suis du Maroc je parle arabe mais je
suis juive donc c'est incroyable parce
que voilà je parle pas hébreu je parle
et je suis française de nationalité et
la musique nous réunit dans tout ça de
manière mais tellement forte puisque on
a chanté Purcell en anglais
on perding en français c'est une
traduction de l'allemand enfin on est
dans le le multiculturel et le tous
vivre ensemble et la musique permet ça
parce que quand on dit dauphin Rémi le
monde entier comprend même les Anglais
qui disent à Ibis ils savent aussi dire
de Rémi fa sol la si do ça c'est un très
beau message
et nous avons profité de cet entretien
avec Costa Gavras le parrain de cette
douzième semaine du son pour lui
demander son impression après les
élections en Grèce et la victoire du
parti de la gauche radicale cerisa pour
le réalisateur Franco grec né à Athènes
et qui a quitté son pays natal pour
Paris pendant ces années de lycée ces
élections marquent un changement
important vous allez l'entendre on
l'écoute c'est ton micro de David
charpentier
je pense que c'est très bien que ça soit
passé comme cela et j'espère que le
niveau des gens en Grèce vont
appliquer la politique qu'ils ont
préconisé parce que je trouve que
surtout sur le plan culturel j'ai pensé
une politique très très intéressante il
s'agit passionnant de la Grèce il est
bien compris tout le monde me dit il
s'agit d'un mouvement beaucoup plus bas
beaucoup plus rare qui a commencé un peu
en Italie en Espagne un peu partout
et puis concernant à l'international la
section des Jeunes Communistes
désyvelines organisent avec les
étudiants communistes à l'université de
Versailles 50 ans en Yvelines une
conférence sur la situation en Palestine
ce jeudi 5 février sur le campus de
Guyancourt de 12h30 à 14h30 il sera
question du parcours de Salah à mourir
un jeune franco-palestinien qui a passé
7 ans de sa vie en prison la conférence
est ouverte aux étudiants à l'université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
donc sur le site de Guyancourt on part
pour trap ou l'espace social de
citoyenneté et d'insertion propose des
ateliers linguistiques bureautique
sportif mais aussi et diététique le
reportage de Yolaine Thorez et d'Élodie
moine
tous les mardis c'est trappistes
s'affairent en cuisine et prépare le
déjeuner un atelier collectif proposé
ici dans les locaux de l'esqui l'espace
social de citoyenneté et d'insertion ils
accueillent des publics bénéficiaires
des minima sociaux comme le RSA et les
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée ils
viennent orienter par le assistante
sociale de secteur ou par les
conseillers dupli le plan local
d'insertion par l'emploi et en fait nous
on les accueille ici ensuite choisissent
des ateliers collectifs tout s'engager
depuis quatre mois au moins ces
personnes ont choisi l'atelier cuisine
et hygiène alimentaire c'est apprendre à
faire des menus équilibrés à cuisiner
aussi plutôt qu'acheter tout prêt on
peut aussi faire les courses ensemble
pour apprendre à gérer un budget après
c'est ainsi un moment de convivialité
c'est à dire qu'on va préparer tous
ensemble les plats on apprend des choses
on rigole et ensuite on déjeune ensemble
d'habitude il déjeune ensemble mais ce
jour-là pour la première fois
cet espace financé en partie par le
Conseil Général et le pli de 50 ans en
Yvelines propose également un
accompagnement individualisé pour un
parcours d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle
dans un instant sur notre antenne le 7 8
sociétés avec Catherine zulato et ses
invités il sera question de la
cybercriminalité cette semaine juste le
temps de vous montrer une dernière photo
Inaya 31 mois la voici sa famille habite
à Guy en cours elle est en compétition
pour le titre de Bébé Cadum 2015 11
finaliste pour les 90 ans de cette
élection vous pouvez danser déjà voter
pour elle pour soutenir Inaya elle
représente toute la région Île-de-France
sur le site Magic maman.com vous avez
jusqu'au 8 février c'est la fin de ce
journal je vous retrouve demain aux
mêmes horaires pour un nouveau point sur
l'actualité local 18h pour la première
édition en direct très bonne soirée